a second coronavirus vaccine now
awaiting approval by u.s
regulators moderna announced its vaccine
is ready
and if approved for emergency use the
company will start rolling out the first
doses of the vaccine
by late december we have worked very
closely with operation of our speed
and as we said you know we should have
up to 20 million doses
by the end of the year so as soon as we
get approval uh general kernel and his
teams are going to
get hold of a vaccine we have and start
shaping it in the country
his goal is to vaccinate americans
within 24 hours from approval
moderna is a small pharmaceutical
company based in cambridge massachusetts
that has never successfully brought a
vaccine to market
it got a big jump on its competitors
because it started working aggressively
on a covet vaccine back in january
the very day china released the genetic
data on the coronavirus
that early foresight is now paying off
the company saying it hopes to produce
as many as 500 million coveted vaccine
doses
next year alone earlier this month new
york-based vaccine maker pfizer
and its german partner bayentech
announced its vaccine was also being
submitted for approval
and could roll out 50 million doses this
year
with pfizer we at the fda announced an
advisory committee for december the 10th
and if everything is on track everything
proves out what uh
what it appears to be we could be
looking at approval within days after
that
moderna is basically one week behind
that distribution of the vaccines could
be a challenge
that is fast approaching the vaccines
must be kept in cold temperatures
at all times during transport and
storage or face the risk of spoiling
and being ineffective but it doesn't
matter how many vaccines are available
if people decide they don't want to take
them here in the united states one poll
showed that nearly 40 percent of
americans
said they have no plans to take the
coronavirus vaccine
and within minority communities
particularly blacks and latinos
the distrust runs even deeper with the
same poll showing that nearly half
said when it comes to the vaccine no
thanks
on monday new york governor andrew cuomo
said
more outreach needs to be done to build
trust with minorities
to take the vaccine blacks died at twice
the rate
that whites died brown died at one and a
half times the rate that whites died
they are less served by the health care
facilities we need a special outreach
effort
federal government has provided no
funding to do that
but global health officials say it's a
problem around the world
we have seen around the world a growing
hesitancy about vaccine in general
and about a coveted vaccine in
particular at the same time
distrust is growing for other public
health intervention
while there is growing anticipation of
the vaccine rollouts health officials
caution it will likely
be several more months before
distribution is ramped up
to meet global demand to truly have a
chance
to end the pandemic once and for all
gabriel zondo
al jazeera new york